when it comes to delivering a memorable
intense experience not many games can
match up to the original Dark Souls many
fans swear by the approach from software
takes with its bleak action RPG series
has become one of the most challenging
and anxiety-inducing franchises in
recent memory with the new release of
Dark Souls remastered on switch the
series makes its way to the Nintendo
console for the first time bringing with
it its particular style of high-pressure
gameplay set within a haunting world
while it isn't as technically impressive
as other current gen releases it's still
an admirable port that reinforces what
makes Dark Souls so memorable it also
makes effective use of switches
capabilities as a portable console which
in turn offers a slightly different feel
to the souls experience that feels
surprisingly refreshing
the switch version is very much in line
with what came before with other
releases of remastered in addition to
offering up a refined online experience
the remaster features all available DLC
and along with touched up visuals
however due to the limitations of the
system's hardware it seen some clear
downgrades compared to the previous
versions of remastered while playing
through the switch version it felt more
closely to the original ps3 and 360
releases albeit far more stable running
at a solid 30 frames per second the
doctrine of Dark Souls on switch
displays at 1080p with the handheld mode
set at 720p aside from the drop in
resolution general frame rate between
docked and handheld is largely
consistent which is great when swapping
between the two different modes during a
session if you're used to Dark Souls
remasters performance on the other
platforms the switch version will likely
take some time adjusting to in addition
to some fairly short draw distances on
environmental details the audio quality
sounds far more subdued and quiet
compared to other releases while this
doesn't happen often it can create odd
moments where some sound effects get
drowned out by others
moreover playing dock mode with the joy
cones can often induce some lag with the
camera controls which can be a dire
issue during some careful platforming or
an intense combat encounter
fortunately the day one patch does work
to address these issues to some success
but other technical hiccups still linger
despite these rough edges Dark Souls on
switch is still an impressive port that
manages to keep the souls experience
intact for its new platform and the
surprisingly neat feature it's possible
to pause the game when playing in the
offline mode by backing out to the home
menu or by setting the system to sleep
if you're planning to take Dark Souls
mobile then you'll more than likely make
use of the offline mode often and the
switch version feels much more suited to
it
to properly put this version through its
paces we journey to one of the game's
most notorious levels which frustrated
and unnerved many players upon its
original release Blighttown the derelict
shanty town full of diseased creatures
was an unnerving descent into a
grotesque atmosphere filled with narrow
walkways and an infamously unstable
framerate many years later it's still
one of the game's most memorable and
feared areas and in the switch version
it's fortunately able to keep a stable
30 frames per second throughout the most
notable success that Dark Souls
remastered has on the switch aside from
the sheer fact that it runs properly on
the hardware is how it can feel much
more like an involved journey thanks to
the handheld mode you're now able to
bring Dark Souls with you on the go as a
returning player it often felt like I
was bundling up with an engrossing book
voraciously exploring and unearthing the
game's many locations in an interesting
way playing in handheld mode can make
for a more personal experience with Dark
Souls which is something that's entirely
exclusive to the switch release while
the switches portability feature can
often feel overstated for other games it
does however amplify the core of what
Dark Souls is all about over the course
of your personal story and game which is
on a road paved by defeat small
victories and occasional humiliation
you'll eventually come to a major win
making the challenging journey feel
worthwhile while Dark Souls remaster on
switch possesses some odd quirks and
isn't as technically impressive as as
current-gen counterparts it still
retains the heart of what the original
game is all about
to this day Dark Souls remains a
watershed moment for the action RPG
genre getting to re-experience many of
the game's most nerve-wracking and
iconic moments can be satisfying in its
own right but coupled with the switches
flexible play style this equally
haunting and triumphant game becomes
even more of an involved journey